someone said you dressed up as me once
did you uh
yes well in high school we had a
in one of my speech classes we had a
balloon debate
so the goal was to
embody a certain public figure of your
choosing
and then debate these other public
figures and try to convince
them uh the class that you've
contributed the most to society
so in retrospect i chose to be conan
o'brien
because i was a big conan fan and still
very nice of you so
and the idea is that you're all in a hot
air balloon and you have to justify who
gets tossed out and who stays
yes that's the idea who are the other
who are the other people in the hot air
balloon with you oh i think there's like
a rosa parks
oh my gosh oh no
i think i i lost to tony morrison i
think tony morrison really
of course you did of course you did
rosa parks tony morrison that's terrible
oh
boy no after everything rosa parks was
went through to be then
told that you have to chop out of a
balloon it's terrible no
yeah i think i think uh i'm so ashamed
that i was in with that group
and i hope that you just dove out of the
balloon immediately yeah i didn't
i didn't last super long and i probably
did i hope you did
i didn't last super long yes i was in
there with socrates
rosa parks uh tony morrison christ
[Laughter]
and then conan o'brien's in the balloon
who's the first that should go well
uh let's debate this that's not a debate
oh but you know what you did think
outside the box and that's cool
everybody else seems kind of obvious
yeah i guess so
i'm trying to i'm trying to help no
that's true that's true they all chose
people that are just
revered right i'm gonna just say it and
you'd chose someone who
uh revered maybe by some um uh
but um yeah i don't belong in that
company at all
i i so i'm so glad i didn't have to be
there to witness it right because
that's the kind of thing if i if that
had been televised or if i'd seen it and
they said here's tony morrison here's
jesus christ you know here's buddha
here's and then
conan o'brien i would have thrown up all
over myself
yeah and i do think in all honesty it
was probably like the costume was a
little half-assed
i might have uh done a little bit better
i really just
wore one of my dad's suits and that was
pretty much it and was like i'm conan
o'brien
so wait you didn't you didn't put an i
look at your impression of me is that i
just
you can't see this but i'm gonna
describe it you put your hands in the
air
and bobbed side to side yeah uh like uh
a cartoon uh chipmunk
um you didn't put a wig on or anything
well i didn't i didn't have the budget
for a conan wig
i don't know those things probably go
for a lot of money i don't know
those things
hey look my conan wig is very reasonable
okay it's the one i wear on the show
and it's it's it's uh available uh you
can get it on etsy
and it's 35 you just have to keep it in
the freezer because it starts to rot